our final speaker is Joseph Gerson he is
the director of programs and director of
the peace and Economic Security program
of the American Friends Service
Committee otherwise known as the Quakers
and he's that the director of the
Northeast region he has written several
books illustrating the deadly connection
between nuclear weapons and foreign
military interventions I know Joe for a
long time having worked with him in
anti-nuclear movements in the United
States as well as internationally so Joe
has a different subject today which is
not directly related to the operational
aspects of the nuclear weapons but about
international tensions and it is really
a primarily a political weapon
ultimately so the technical issues are
of course important but it is we have to
realize it is primarily a political
weapon and to fight nuclear weapons we
have to take up the political and social
fight thank you
they're okay so I'm the historian and an
organizer on this panel and I have to
say I sort of wish I was speaking after
max because my talk is not going to be
quite as uplifting my talk is going to
kind of build in some ways from elaine's
and really in the tradition of pogo
we've met the enemy and he's us you know
the reality is that i can point to some
elements of the nature of our state
which may be a little bit unsettling so
to begin with i worked fairly closely
with dan ellsberg over the years dan was
a nuclear policy senior policy advisor
to Kennedy Johnson and briefly to Nixon
and he he's taught us that the notion
comments in nearly all Americans that no
nuclear weapons have been used since
nagasaki is mistaken again and again
generally in secret from the American
public the US the US nuclear weapons
have been used in precisely the same way
that a gun is used when you pointed at
someone's head in a direct confrontation
whether or not you pull the trigger this
shouldn't surprise us with reference was
made earlier to Hiroshima and Nagasaki
the reality if you look at the burns
quote at the end was that that was
principally attack related to Russia so
the United States could bring the war to
an immediate end consolidate its control
over northern China Manchuria and Korea
rather than let the the Soviets do so
and one of the things one of the results
coming out of that was also the belief
among the senior figures of our elite
that the weapons were useful the weapon
had succeeded and they could build from
there Noam Chomsky who teaches at this
institution essentially has taught us
that we've used our nuclear weapons many
many times in ways that essentially
prevent anyone from coming to defend
those that were determined to attack so
think here in terms of Panama think here
in terms
Vietnam you know the long history that
will kind of points ooh I want to
concede that there is and has been a
what we understand is the traditional
way that mutual that deterrence works
mutual assured destruction but the
reality beneath that is that we've used
our nuclear weapons in other ways we
have to kind of go at what deterrence
theory is first what you have here is
from the initial HW Bush nuclear
doctrine in which they said that the
focus of u.s. deterrence efforts is to
influence potential adversaries to
withhold actions intended to impact US
national interests the central focus
being deterrence is for one nation to
exert such influence over a potential
adversaries decision process that the
potential adversary makes a deliberate
choice to refrain from a course of
action not to necessarily prevent them
from watching their nuclear weapons but
that they should not take a course of
action that in some way impinges on us
global influence and power more recently
we have the statement from just last
month saying that the value of the
bomber force is sending political
signals is clear and convincing which is
to say that we repeatedly use our
nuclear capable bombers and we're about
to build a whole new generation in order
to threaten to initiate nuclear war it's
at the core of our policy when timings
I'll keep going we've heard throughout
the morning about the dangers of nuclear
war they're real and increasing adding
to the list that we have heard already
there's the possibility of
insubordination at different levels of
the military and you look at the Cuban
Missile Crisis we knew it that in some
detail we have to now fear about the
possibility of cyber hacking into our
nuclear missile sites terrorism we've
been hearing about that all week but to
also think in terms of who
under our drones or what happens when
we're threatening other countries with
first-rate nuclear attack is that
terrorism what happened in Hiroshima was
that terrorism and then we also have the
possibilities of the failure of
deterrence reference was made to you
know the development of the new
generation of nuclear weapons and you
know they're being designed to be quote
unquote more usable I can't go into this
history in great depth but this is
simply a history of us first strike
preparations and threats in order to
maintain us hegemony in the oil-rich
Middle East note here that it began in
nineteen forty six in a crisis over Iran
when the Soviet Union did not have
nuclear weapons 1973 was really what
would push me into this when Nixon and
Kissinger essentially allowed filled my
ear to surround and threaten the total
destruction of the Egyptian Third Army
after the already a ceasefire Sadat call
for the United States and Russia to
intervene the United States was not
happy about that and so moved to a
massive nuclear war in the last days of
the water of the Watergate crisis we can
go into more detail on any of those
surprisingly at least to me as I began
researching this was the number of
threats in relationship to maintaining
us dominance in Asia Pacific beginning
in 1950 with the outbreak of the Korean
War Eisenhower's reelection was in part
based on his commitment to bring that
war to an end and he threatened nuclear
attack to to move from what was a
functional ceasefire to to enormousness
and it was learning at Eisenhower's knee
that Nixon in turn learned what he
called the madman theory which he then
implemented during the Vietnam War and
the accidents in the DMZ in Korea
absolute chilling to the point that the
US senior commander in in South Korea
thought that
war and nuclear attacks us use of
nuclear attacks were absolutely imminent
and asked for authority to launch the US
nuclear weapons without without having
to hear from Washington and of course
these dangerous didn't end with the Cold
War we have repeatedly done simulated
nuclear attacks against North Korea and
if you look at the number of times the
United States has prepared and
threatened to initiate war a nuclear war
against North Korea plus the history of
having destroyed about 99% of all
buildings in North Korea during the
Korean War you can understand why the
North Koreans might have moved as they
have seeing a time thing which is not
happy so then a long history here of
post Cold War nuclear threats beginning
with the 1991 war and of course we had
the mentioned earlier the increased
dangers with with Russia initially in
relationship to Ukraine and then also
Syria of course the United States is not
the only nation that's done this this is
a summary history of other countries who
have prepared and threatened to initiate
nuclear war during wars in international
crises I want to point to some of the
lessons from the Cuban Missile Crisis
first we learned that political forces
when a country can drive political
leaders to do the irrational John
Kennedy turned to Bobby at one point and
said look if I hadn't if I hadn't
responded as I had I would have been
impeached and we need to remember for
example what happened in in in China
after these Japanese moved to
nationalize the Senkaku Islands massive
riots repression and the government
feeling it had to kind of let things go
wild for a while there's the danger of a
strange love Ian military
insubordination we had in the middle of
that crisis on the one hand senior
generals upping the level of the death
come alert without authorization the
time when Kennedy wanted quiet in the
Caribbean so Khrushchev could consider
one of those proposals didn't want any
tax law
on Soviet submarines was the best time
for our troops our Navy to practice
depth charging of submarines and we came
within within moments of the end we
heard before hear about the b61 12
Cartwright saying if we can drive down
the yield it becomes more usable once
they're used what do you think the
response of the so-called enemy is going
to be we also have another one with the
air-launched cruise missile I'm sure
we'll hear about that kind of this
afternoon and then I think we need to
look at some of the deeper levels of the
United States and Russia the United
States has in violation of the
commitment made to Gorbachev expanded
NATO to Russians borders the Russians
can't help but remember Napoleon coming
from the West the Kaiser coming from the
west Hitler coming from the west we
heard before about the levels of fear in
Russia and this is what's driving them
plus their their conventional
inferiority driving them to become
increasingly reliant so if we want to
get to the bill down we're going to need
to deal with some of the other
dimensions that that are driving the
arms race similarly we have real
challenges in relationship to China this
is a photograph I picked up off of a
presentation at Harvard what you see
here or Japanese and Chinese warships
Taiwanese fishing trawlers the
likelihood of an incident spinning out
of control and the Chinese have told us
this many times is extremely frightening
because when you get the political
factors that come in behind it it's the
kind of thing that can drive 22 to the
ultimate then here on the subject of
hope and fear we have Ted Cruz who's
telling us that he would make the desert
glow and then the question is do you
have confidence in Trump who
initially and one of the debates didn't
even know what the triode was and now
tells us he won't take any of the cards
off the table we've got Putin on the
other side who is telling us that he
seriously considered the use of nuclear
weapons if necessary to defend the
control of Crimea almost done Hillary
tells us in one hand she was right there
with all all options on the table in
relationship to Iran and she tells us
that nuclear weapons will be abolished
in some century what what what drives
what drives the global arms race will
Mohamed ElBaradei and if you go to any
of the international conferences like
the one I was talking about earlier will
you here is a double standard the United
States can threaten annihilation of all
these other countries but but but they
can't and deep deep anger and rage on
this last slide here second last slide
Joseph rotblat one the one senior
scientist Manhattan Project who quit
over moral moral considerations and has
told us very clearly that humanity faces
a stark choice we either completely
eliminate them or they will be used to
our detriment to say the least reference
was made earlier to article six and
finally to two books that you might find
helpful in building deeper into this or
my book and then Nixon's nuclear specter
just came out about 10 days ago and i
think it's a it's a very important book
in well worth the read